hey I'm Deckard movie links calm here we
are with the lovely Gillian hi good to
see you
I've got questions first question is is
first date rom-com yeah okay I guess I
don't have any other questions
Wow Brittany what's with your hair it's
huge it's like that hair ate your other
hair okay fYI everyone I'm feeling very
insecure today and you know how I'm
normally the most confident woman in
America yes but when this bitch comes to
town Gillian Jacobs doesn't everybody
love her that goblin face
hell no I kind of think she's a favorite
well trust me she's like my best friend
she's awful oh wait that's right you you
were in that sitcom with her believe it
blame it on the back sir well you play
daddy fanny yes what kind of sick
comedy write our names are overweight
twelve-year-old fatty like that was my
given name on the show it's so up
hey what's up dork squad everyone is
here
okay Kevin honestly don't start with me
hmm
buddy Fanny's got her panties in a bunch
are you ready for your big reunion porky
I cannot even right now Wow oh my god
it's so good to see you honestly like I
really miss you good to see you look
amazing so do you oh my god your skin is
so amazing I wanna know where you like a
jacket what what oh my god this is so
exciting yes very exciting first date I
thought it was good
oh great yes I'm so glad totally like
you know not gonna get a lot of praise
it's not gonna like hurt your career too
much I always count on you to give me
straight up because that's like our
dynamic right right little mean and I
just take it I finally finished book 23
of the gland Thor saga well
congratulations on that am I supposed to
be interested in that stupid book you're
writing in your mom's basement about
dragons all right they're not called
dragons at glan Thor they're called fire
slugs you all right men you don't look
so hot do not mix tequila and
cockfighting ever
well that's funny because I had nine
vodka cran last night myself and I feel
great I also got up around seven miles
meditated did a little manscaping all
before 7:00 a.m.
get your scrotum - yes I brought you a
gift
what don't feel bad if you didn't get me
anything I'm so I'm humiliated you've
really shown me up okay here it is on
the cover of TV tonight and that's me
way in the front doing my signature pose
and then that's Gillian they put her
like in the back and then the dogs even
in front of Gillian yeah this is amazing
I feel like I should sign this like
you'll always be fatty to me okay do you
have a pen I'll sign it right now oh no
you don't need to put that on there can
we just put this down here so it's not
in the frame for the interview okay sure
sounds good thank you so much maybe we
could put it here how do you not have
Wi-Fi at the pool hey um I know I'm the
new guy so maybe I don't get it but why
are you all so miserable what are you
talking about just gave me the
audition we get to talk to movie stars
in beautiful hotels with free food for
cash money most people would kill for
that chance my young sweet pad on we'll
get you jaded yet yeah I guess my big
break was when I got into Juilliard do
you remember when the audition together
yeah my god how crazy would that be if
you had gotten in instead of me we were
just like swapped lives Oh gross I
always wondered why you didn't get in do
you think it's cuz you can't cry on cue
no I can't cry on cue you can yeah I
didn't want to go to Juilliard it was
like too little a stuffy I wanted to go
City College why don't you just like
crying Q now if you can do it I know I'm
going to
here's the book you're squinting hold on
okay I'm gonna give you a hint I do it
all the time just think about your
career but you have a great career no I
think about your career it's like
I'm sorry like that
so so good to see you yeah you too
give me that please
just about as sweet as the kick
in the balls
between love and loss between men and
women it always begins with a first date
Gillian Jacobs first date
you